one of the most intriguing behaviors
that has baffled the quantum world is
entanglement entanglement is the
interaction between isolated particles
how does a discrete particle affect
another one from a distance quantum
mechanics has yet to find a rational
explanation for this phenomenon here's
what some of the experts have to say
about entanglement in particular in
quantum mechanics in general the most
absurd the most crazy the most
ridiculous prediction that quantum
mechanics maze is entanglement it is
impossible to even comprehend don't even
ask me why
don't ask me what you're going to how it
works because it's an illegal question
quantum physics is notoriously weird
strange and counterintuitive to this day
still have great difficulty in
understanding it still learn quantum
mechanics you're you're never really the
same again
the short answer is we don't know this
is the fundamental mystery of quantum
mechanics the reason why quantum
mechanics is difficult this is something
we scientists argued passionately about
now for almost a hundred years and
there's still no consensus the most
magical thing is that in quantum physics
an object can be in more than one place
at the same time because it may suggest
that information has traveled
instantaneously faster than the speed of
light from one particle to another I
don't understand it I don't know that
anyone does spooky action at a distance
as Einstein called it the rules that
govern this subatomic world hint at a
universe that's just as mysterious as
science fiction
in fact quantum physics may suggest that
reality is simply a figment of our
imagination
breathtaking testimonials after a
hundred years of quantum mechanics
perhaps all these blunt confessions are
important of something else maybe they
indicate that the theories have not
discovered how the subatomic universe
works maybe they're modeling it with the
wrong entity maybe it's time to question
the particle hypothesis under the Rope
hypothesis entanglement is a no brainer
it's not even a mystery the quantum atom
consists of electron beads that orbit
the nucleus when the electron beam Falls
to a lower energy level the atom emits a
photon a packet of energy and when an
atom absorbs a photon the electron beam
rises to a higher energy level quantum
provides no rational physical mechanism
for why the electron bead doesn't drift
away nevertheless whether electron beads
or photons discrete particles and waves
have two fatal shortcomings they are
one-way mechanisms they can only travel
in one direction and they can't generate
pull
this creat one-way billiard balls can
only push in contrast the rope
hypothesis proposes that two atoms are
bound together by a pair of twined DNA
like threads a rope like entity that
physically and permanently binds them
the electric thread forms the star like
proton in the nucleus the Magnetic
thread coils around and weaves the
electron shell that encapsulate s' the
nucleus the electromagnetic ropes from
every atom in the universe converge upon
an atom and contribute to its structure
the atom is a tiny heart that expands
and contracts pumping torsion waves to
every atom in the universe when it
contracts it releases a link of rope a
segment known in quantum as a photon
when the atom expands it reels in a
length of rope by doing so the atom
torques the electromagnetic rope light
consists of a torsion propagating in two
directions along the electromagnetic
rope from atom to atom three-dimensional
torsion waves arrive at your eyes from
an atom in the Andromeda galaxy by
propagating along the electromagnetic
rope
so what is the problem with entanglement
why is it so badly to the particle
mathematicians let's allow the experts
to tell you in their own words why they
can't explain entanglement with discrete
particles when two subatomic particles
interact they can become entangled that
means their spin position or other
properties become linked through a
process unknown to modern science that
means of a scientist observes one
entangled particle and forces it to spin
clockwise the other entangled particle
will immediately start spinning in the
opposite direction that seems intriguing
but it's hardly earth-shattering until
you consider that the two entangled
particles can be separated by billions
of light years and still the moment you
observe one particle spin you've
dictated the other particles spin two
particles can become entangled if
they're close together and their
properties become linked remarkably
quantum mechanics says that even if you
separated those particles sending them
in opposite directions it could remain
entangled inextricably connected quantum
particles can be linked to the crossface
measuring one thing can in fact
instantly affect its distant partner as
if the space between them didn't even
exist
the one thing that Einstein thought was
impossible spooky action at a distance
actually happens
so how does the electromagnetic probe
explain entanglement as first get an
introduction from David bone a
researcher who studied entanglement
great detail what quantum mechanics and
relativity suggest the world is not made
of separate elements but it is unbroken
whole in flowing movement in the sense
that things which are far apart are
still related deeply it is possible to
have all these things connected together
over very long distances into a whole
what if we assume that all atoms and
universe are interconnected
what interconnects any two atoms is the
electromagnetic rope along which torsion
waves propagate from my amp the rope
Perls
clockwise hopefully from your end rope
is truly counterclockwise now let's
reverse the direction from my end the
rope twirls counterclockwise hopefully
from your end the Rope is trailing
clockwise discrete particles have no
rational way of explaining action at a
distance that's why the theorists were
compelled to invent excuses and
ludicrous theories this is how they
ended up confessing that they don't
understand how the subatomic world works
they painted themselves into a corner
the electromagnetic rope on the other
hand is an extended object that binds
any two atoms and explains clockwise and
counterclockwise spin in fact the rope
need not move at all recall that quantum
mechanics alleges that the atom emits
energy in discrete packets under the
rope model the alleged folk
of quantum mechanics is a link of the
rope
when the blue thread is on top for the
atom over here the red thread had better
be in the top position as it melts into
the atom over there if the link is to
preserve its integrity
both Planck's quantum packet and de
Broglie Z Quay ssin require an integral
number of links indeed all these years
the particle theorists were staring at
the answer right there in front of them
when two subatomic particles interact
they can become entangled that means
their spin position or other properties
become linked through a process unknown
to modern science unknown to modern
science what did they bind these two
particles with the theorists had no
choice but to link their particles with
an extended entity to illustrate how one
could influence the other all they had
to do all these years is replaced their
particles in ways with the
electromagnetic rope
therefore what is so baffling to
particle theorists is easily explained
under the rope hypothesis it's not even
an issue it's kindergarten stuff all we
need to do is abandon the particle
hypothesis